welcome to this video we are raelia pen
if he is playing this is a game against
this guy but he's not playing yeah the
game before that I did not upload I
simply terminated it quickly because it
was a known sheet out for some reason he
was so bent this is not good for my
general mood it's really is this
dreadful you know I have zero out of
four against this bloody computer and
he's not getting banned yeah I have to
report him again not much more that I
can do yeah okay this is not this guy
right not not to be confused here this
is a normal um yeah flesh and bones
normal player right so let's see young
Jack my good old bogo I have a hunch
that I had this against him before I've
got a slight advantage snow on the clock
due to his late start okay we have this
very sharp variation maybe you will play
with H for Bishop d3 of c5h for very
sharp variation no he's playing them the
old in the old way let's say with the
capture yeah it's interesting Queen to
see 20 here I might be able to get away
with age 6 in the other line with
immediate h4h 6 is not good I didn't
want to play g6 here because of e-cigs
okay let's see I think I'm should be in
decent shape here anyway I don't really
believe much in the other lines I think
white should go for this some very um
very sharp edge flow variation what well
not that this is terrible for white but
I think black is normally quite okay
yeah don't know if this was very precise
though the capture them hmm I don't want
to simply allow him to recapture them
man it wasn't a very precise mulata this
is that hole okay let's see what I can
do here yeah queen bee six tries to keep
the part for a moment at least and
possibly a5 a4 is an idea then 95 yeah
let's do this I can't play rook give one
hmm now playing too quickly here not
really thinking I'm thinking things
through to the end yeah I could not take
because of Bishop h7 that's not not very
very comfortable here this position
you're not not terrible or anything but
not good okay e seven is hanging ok I'm
going to going to take and give him the
two bishops which it's not so terrible
at the moment I don't have a bad piece
on any a great structural problem
possibly queen bee three to two trade
queens not sure if it helps me but it's
a it's an idea because of his weakened
to be three square also I just have
things like night to e6 or pawn to d4 I
have some some active ideas and well he
looks like it looks like he might try
something on the Kings side hmm okay
that's not something I'm did expect very
much once you get the Queen to g4 it
seems ok I'm going going back IAM night
only success is decently placed yeah
yeah I thought 94 would be would be very
decent on is he having something great
down exchange sack on the tactic I don't
see it so I'm going to do it if I get
his light squared Bishop oh this is this
pin I did not really appreciate this
move looks kind of awkward but it seems
to be man that's very awkward actually
hmm yeah now we can retreat can we treat
this bishop maybe we should be one I
have discoveries with the night but I
really did not want to do this here this
is not a plant planned a planned line
Bishop see one yeah I can't play maybe
night see to as cheeky as it looks 9c
223 night you know i can take f2 then
that is quite a lot of material any
other square are no I have to do that
Quinn d3s is really funny now with Queen
h7 to come but I can escape to e7 I
don't see don't see a mate down and 23 I
can't play Bishop f2 as well so it's not
not just them yeah kk so he's giving it
up in this way taking it yeah ok what is
this a primary attacking idea
probably um II six right e 6 and then
maybe queen to g6 so maybe a rupee aid
bishop age six is not a problem Queen d3
I can take F jump so let's do this to
make e6 less dangerous maybe Bishop d4
as an idea yeah he still has some
compensation here definitely as those
bishops are strong good news is that is
not very very quickly and it will be he
will be in trouble to to to to manage
the time threatening bishop f2 now
looking at this unprotected see one
Bishop own okay I can take now right no
I cannot Oh almost but I cannot take
rupee five maybe no not really Bishop g4
queen bee three maybe four in b3 yeah
that's not bad Queen d1 checkmate and
exchanging Queens as the combined threat
let's say and if I get the Queen's off I
should be in good shape don't get
checkmated then yeah a bit of a strange
game and I felt like being in trouble
but then all of a sudden I was okay no
not quite clear what what happened there
to be honest why I'm sound yeah somehow
somehow this some guy is stumbled into
this tactic but I think that all this
wasn't wasn't really the best I mean not
just 60 certainty okay he went look he
won and now I'm kind of making mistakes
here this is not the best move pretty
sure
i played this bit bit too hastily I have
I have some other moves that I can play
the promise he does not really yeah it's
not clear what he's doing next night f1
maybe you know the thing is okay I took
and he had a useful moving that so that
you can take back the pawn if i play
move that is useful for me like a five
for example that gained some space then
he cannot play that be three obviously
because of this layer maybe he can but
it's kind of awkward so maybe he goes
here and then I can take this is a
better version of all this so this is
taking was probably a bit them a bit too
early okay I think I'm still quite okay
but it's certainly not the best best way
to play yeah I had to take and and this
kind of thing yeah maybe Bishop e3 as a
good move white must be a bit better
here he's got the better structure and
and the two bishops oh he must be a
little bit better at least we should be
three as maybe an ID i am here this is
this looks kind of okay okay i didn't
really appreciate queen III the computer
gives this as a line what would I saw
that but I was thinking that after you
six let's say I couldn't believe I'm
worse the computer says it's equal very
typical yeah you have a very sharp line
and the concerts are that that's not
very exciting it's just a raw be form
for bit should be to what looks very
dangerous compounds to do this and
return the exchange that's a funny line
and gifts this is equal well I have
equal material now okay but this was
played Bishop c5 yeah and maybe this is
this is just a mistake do 2nite c2 he
has two comps s queen age 3 with about
equality yeah i would take then and i
was thinking maybe just queen to his six
this kind of thing blocking with the
Queen and I have a decent structure here
for this all in light squares his be to
point is a bit backward and I have the
deponent I'm okay I'm it's it's not it's
about equal but here yeah he stumbled
into that maybe he was really planning
Queen d3m but if you look at it i mean i
have the choice i can take here or I can
take I'm sorry it was a bit much here I
can take you and y esas check check but
this is not leading to much create this
is just just not working I think check I
mean I only looked like until up to this
point i was thinking okay he's not even
threatening a serious check so it should
be okay yeah well the comp gives Luke g8
forcing the Queen trade which ends at
mmm yeah it is not it's not working it's
not really not really not working yeah
and then I was an exchanger I don't
think I hope I didn't didn't screw it
screw it up queen bee three was was bad
i er no I mean it was possible even
earlier but this is a very clean
solution yeah okay i hope you enjoyed
this game thanks for watching